antes de empezar con la nomenclatura de
los al kilos repasemos lo que vimos en
el vídeo de hibridación esp lo que vimos
en ese vídeo es que cuando tenemos un
enlace triple entre dos carbonos estos
dos carbonos están híbridos a dos de
tipo sp y otra cosa que vimos en ese
vídeo es que el ángulo entre estos
enlaces es de 180 grados por lo que la
geometría de esta molécula por lo menos
en este pedazo es lineal
ok tiene una geometría lineal si no te
acuerdas de estas cosas tienes que
volver a ver ese vídeo pero bueno otra
cosa que vimos es que este enlace triple
se conforma de un enlace de tipo sigma y
dos enlaces de tipo pi pero bueno esta
molécula tiene grupos al kilos de los
dos lados del enlace triple entonces es
un al 'chino' dy substituido pero
tenemos un nombre más especial para este
tipo de alquimia y ese es que es un el
'chino' interno entonces vamos a
escribirlo por aquí
al 'chino'
interno
y le ponemos este nombre porque el
enlace triple está en el interior de la
cadena
a diferencia del al 'chino' terminal que
ahora vamos a dibujar tenemos por aquí
un grupo alquiló el enlace triple otro
carbono y aquí en lugar de poner otro
grupo al kilo podemos poner simplemente
un hidrógeno y así se acaba la cadena y
tenemos aquí un alquilo terminal
al 'chino' terminal
al que también podemos llamar como un
alquilo mono sustituido ahora es
importante distinguir entre estos dos
tipos de algunos porque tienen distintas
propiedades químicas como vamos a ver
más adelante en algún vídeo bueno ahora
sí vamos a empezar con la nomenclatura
vamos a poner a la quinoa más famoso de
todos que tiene únicamente 2 carbonos
aunque tenemos un carbono con un triple
enlace con otro carbono y cada uno está
enlazado con un hidrógeno ahora como se
llama esta molécula tenemos que el
prefijo para moléculas de 2 carbonos es
eta y que la terminación para los al
'chino' ses y n
entonces simplemente juntamos estas dos
cosas y nos queda
de que son dos carbonos y uno de que es
un al 'chino' que tiene un triple enlace
así es que esta molécula se llama tino
sin embargo también se le conoce como
acetileno estoy segura que has escuchado
hablar acerca del acetileno act no de
las antorchas de acetileno que bueno de
hecho puedes hacer unos juegos muy
padres bajo el agua con el acetileno
acetileno es el nombre común de ti no es
el nombre más oficial de acuerdo a la
convención iupac pero bueno vamos a
nombrar otros alc y nos tenemos por aquí
un triple enlace y después
esto es por aquí ahora si te fijas en
esta estructura aquí tenemos una línea
recta y eso lo vas a ver en muchísimas
estructuras de louis ok siempre se trata
de preservar la geometría de la molécula
y como tenemos un enlace triple aquí
estas moléculas tienen una geometría
lineal que estamos preservando en esta
estructura bueno pero para ponerle el
nombre lo primero que hacemos es contar
cuántos carbonos tiene aquí tiene 12
45 y el prefijo para cualquier molécula
de 5 carbonos spent si estuviéramos
lidiando con un alka no se llamaría
pantano pero como tenemos un enlace
triple acá esto es un al 'chino' y la
terminación de los algunos es y n o así
es que esta molécula es un pent y no
sino y bueno ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es numerar a los carbonos para
indicar en donde se encuentra el triple
enlace ahora no lo queremos numerar al
azar
queremos numerar los de tal forma que el
triple enlace empiece en el carbono más
chico posible dentro de la numeración y
eso por supuesto significa que tenemos
que empezar la enumeración por acá si es
que éste es el carbono 1 carbono 2 o sea
que el triple enlace empieza en el
carbono 2 carbono 3 4 y 5
y entonces agregamos por aquí 12 jones
21 indicando que el triple enlace
empieza en el segundo carbono como
puedes notar estamos haciendo
exactamente lo mismo que estábamos
haciendo con los algunos pero bueno
ahora veamos otro ejemplo un poquito más
complicado tenemos nuestro famoso triple
enlace para qué y para qué vamos a tener
otro carbono
y por acá otra estructura muy bonita
más o menos así
ahora otra vez para ponerle el nombre a
esta molécula tenemos que buscar la
cadena más larga que contenga el triple
enlace y está por supuesto es este
entonces empezamos enumerando 1 2
7 tenemos una cadena con 7 carbonos y un
triple enlace así es que tenemos un es
de 7 carbonos y no de que es un al
'chino' pero bueno ahora tenemos que
encontrar en qué carbono empieza el
triple enlace y estos dos grupos metí
los así es que tenemos que enumerar esta
cadena ahora uno puede llegar a
confundirse un poco porque si empezamos
a enumerar desde la derecha tenemos un
grupo metilo en el segundo carbono y si
empezamos a enumerar por la izquierda
tenemos al triple enlace en el segundo
carbono pero no hay que confundirse aquí
el que tiene la prioridad es el triple
enlace entonces no importa como le
hagamos tenemos que enumerar esta cadena
de tal forma que el triple enlace
empiece en el carbono más chico y eso
significa empezar a numerar por aquí
entonces tenemos que este es el carbono
uno es el carbono 2
4 5 6 y 7 y entonces el triple enlace
empieza en el segundo carbono así es que
ponemos un 2 con un guión por acá y los
grupos metilo están sobre los carbonos 5
y 6 así es que tenemos que poner por
aquí 5,6
de metil
2 7º ahora esta forma de llamarle a esta
molécula está perfectamente de acuerdo a
la convención iupac antigua y muchísimos
profesores de química orgánica siguen
utilizando esta anotación sin embargo
hay una nueva anotación apoyada por la
convención iupac en la que se cambia
este 2 del lugar aquí en medio ok
entonces esta molécula se llamaría 56
dimetil
aunque en realidad ahorita cualquiera de
las dos está bien sólo asegúrate de que
estés utilizando la misma anotación que
tu profesor